esta escalada este aumento en las
amenazas en el lenguaje podría incluso
amenazar la armonía de la cumbre del g7
que hemos visto hasta el momento
boris johnson como lo hemos escuchado ha
dicho palabras más palabras menos que si
la unión europea no modifica el
protocolo de irlanda del norte que está
trayendo muchos problemas a esa región
británica lo que hará entonces es
suspenderlo ya a los países europeos
el presidente francés la canciller
alemana y la misma jefe de la unión
europea ha dicho que no que eso no es
posible que es ley que el reino unido
debe respetar esta ley e implementar el
protocolo de otro lado el presidente
francés emmanuel macrón se reunió con el
presidente de eeuu joe biden en un
cambio de tono el inicio de una nueva
relación un nuevo capítulo vimos mucha
camaradería dijo vaivén que francia eeuu
están en la misma página el presidente
macro dijo que los dos países del g7
está luchando
dar un paso adelante y dejando atrás
esta pandemia del coi 19 y de otra parte
de manifestaciones en el barco de la
cumbre que dice la gente y cómo se está
manejando la seguridad
la seguridad es extrema hay más de 6500
hombres de la policía que incluso han
sido movilizados desde distintas
regiones del reino unido para garantizar
la seguridad de esta cumbre en la que
están las personas más poderosas del
mundo como mencionas ha habido varias
manifestaciones a lo largo de estos días
algunas donde se realiza la cumbre donde
están los líderes en saná efe y aquí en
falmouth donde nos encontramos en la
costa inglesa hoy ha habido dos
manifestaciones una de ellas pidiéndoles
a los líderes del g-7 que tomen acciones
más radicales para exigir el regreso de
la democracia en mi ama recordemos este
país del sureste asiático tuvo un golpe
de estado en febrero de este año y están
exigiendo además la liberación de todos
los presos especialmente de la xxi eran
suc y también otra manifestación una
larga marcha en la que participaron
cientos de personas especialmente
jóvenes promovidas por extensión
rebelión muy colorida llena de música y
pacífica exigiéndoles a los líderes del
g-7 que se reúnen aquí en la costa
inglesa que tomar acciones urgentes
contra el cambio climático